godard
eu vou pedir uma salva de palmas pela
vida ró bom bonito e rural mesmo bonito
algumas pessoas aqui já conhecem e de
certeza que estavam à espera de ouvir
falar do hall da segurança alimentar da
agricultura da terra e da reforma
agrária mas não vai ser tão bem assim
não
quando foi feito o convite para falar
aqui no interesse e respeito e um
carinho e disse que tem que falar com o
tempo adequar a minha mensagem para um
público mais urbano com o público que
ainda não ouviu falar daquilo que são os
mesmo minhas perspectivas sobre a
situação no local
na verdade também a minha perspectiva
sobre a situação urbana
eu vou falar de uma das implicações de
nós não temos feito ainda reformas
rurais obrigações nós não temos feito
reformas agrárias que são necessárias e
uma dessas explicações é precisamente
aquilo que é uma qualidade de vida nas
zonas urbanas e hoje já não é só luanda
lubango benguela lobito huambo têm
exatamente o mesmo problema que nos
sentimos hoje aqui um ano
o problema da qualidade do vídeo é muito
má
o desafio aqui alguém dizer que tens
antes bem feliz
pode até ter dinheiro nesse espaço não
vou naturalmente escolar não vou
argumentar com essa pessoa ou apenas
aconselhar a rever os seus conceitos
também está sem o conceito do bem estar
nesse espaço que nós queremos chamar de
urbano nesse espaço que nós queremos
chamada cidade o que na verdade uma
metamorfose que nunca chegou o seu ciclo
completo e uma metamorfose calar morra
antes muito antes de começar o que nós
temos tava ver aqui nessa cidade a
presenciar nessa cidade não é tanto o
desenvolvimento urbano como as políticas
fazem passar por fazem crer que nós
estamos a ver aqui nessa cidade e sim
senhor
um transplante da bits valores e
costumes do espaço rural para uma cidade
que nós estamos a presenciar aqui uma
ruralização da cidade e isso retiramos a
qualidade de vida tira a qualidade de
vida de quem vive na cidade e eu
levantei desafio aqui pra vocês provar a
responsabilidade de melhorar a sua
melhor qualidade de vida é vós e vossas
responsabilidades
a solução não está em termos mais taxa
de lixo solução não passa por criar mais
impostos ou criamos mais imposto predial
urbano no espaço que não tem
caracterização urbana
a solução está em criar uns mais taxa de
serviço de municipalidade para um espaço
que não tem caracterização própria
a solução está em reformamos os nossos
no nosso espaço rural
a solução passa necessariamente por uma
forma do espaço rural passa evaporam
pela valorização do rural e cada um de
vocês aqui é responsável por fazer isso
por favor não fechassem as portas dos
condomínios na expectativa de que alguém
ia fazer por vocês não cada um de vocês
aqui têm essa missão
e essa mensagem que eu queria passar
para uma população mais urbano
mas por que um preocupo com essa questão
dural eu nasci aqui na cidade vive em
cidades até às 17 20 anos em 1998 meio
decisão muito consciente de largar a
cidade e ir pro campo
na altura vivia na cidade de harare no
zimbabué decidir sair da cidade e fui
colocando a minha mãe tinha tem seis
filhos tinha o mesmo plano para todos os
filhos
eu fui o único que desvia e sair da
cidade e fui pro calma mas quando fui
para o campo mas nos embargo encontrei
um robô lito encontrei o raffles
enquanto raul com perspectiva encontrar
um local com capacidade do terceiro
apenas com a sua agricultura e isso
facilitou a minha integração no meio
rural
seis anos mais tarde a sua convidada a
vir trabalhar para angola vem cá fui
para a província do álbum
e foi na província do amor eu apanhei o
primeiro shopping rural angolano tempo
de guerra e eu tinha trabalhar entre o
homem eo barulho tinha duas opções tinha
qualificações suficientes para sair da
cidade para sair do ano em vez de vir
trabalhar na cidade
optei por ficar optei por ficar no
huambo porque o convívio com aqueles
mais velhos que o com quem eu tinha que
o dia lugar quase numa base diária que
fizeram rever os meus conceitos de
intelectualidade fizeram questionar o
próprio do rio a licenciatura que eu
tinha fizeram rever o contexto o
significado de sua de título de
engenheiro e doutores que nos vá pra
nada e foi a conversar com um desses
mais velhos o que pôs verdadeiramente a
prova que tinha que aprender com eles
em 2003 eu fui contratado pelo
ministério do planejamento para fazer um
estudo sobre a pobreza rali em angola
que eu estou depois deu base serviu de
base para entrar para a estratégia de
combate à pobreza que nós fizemos na
altura que elaboramos foi logo a
primeira foi uma estratégia primeiro
desenhada por uma perspectiva urbana mas
depois eu vi as cidades integrado numa
perspectiva real e eu fiz esse trabalho
e foi nesta caminhada que eu conversei
com o conheciam mais velho maridadi
nestas profundezas do país e em conversa
comigo no jango ele mesmo assim o meu
filho onde a pobreza também a riqueza e
essas duas coisas andam sempre juntas
eu não tinha a dimensão intelectual para
perceber algumas vezes não sabe dizer de
elaboração e disse mesmo assim se vocês
na cidade não partilharem a bolsa presa
conosco no campo nós vamos partilhar a
nossa pobreza com vocês na cidade
mas ainda assim eu não percebi algo mais
velho estava a dizer até chegar a luanda
e sentir o asfixiamento demográfico
desta grande cidade
eu não percebia tem que começar a dar
conta que os miúdos nas zonas rurais
estavam a abandonar o campo e compravam
motas concebido com o papai tá mais pra
te favorece na primeira esquina numa
cidade pouco não conheciam a cidade não
conhecia regras de trânsito
eu não dei conta da dimensão do que mais
velho estava a dizer até chegar aqui na
terra vermelha e vermelha heróis do
longonjo a engrossar a estatística do
mercado informal vendedoras do mercado
informal e se constitui 70 por cento da
força de trabalho de emprego em a nova e
foi nesta situação em que eu comecei a
perceber realmente o que eu estava a
tentar dizer o mesmo dia fui ver uma
comunidade no cunene
aí sim a ficha caiu
quando a família decidiu paulo nós não
queremos ficar aqui porque já não dá
mais
e puseram no carro
esse carro e mel não tive opção vez só
um belo dia fui ao conversar com uma
mais velha tem um daqui da boa entrada
na tabela
é uma pessoa com quem conversava muito
com ela reúne algumas vezes quando eu
quisesse conversar com ele sobre a
situação da terra e partilhei com a
velha uma vitrina o sinceramente do mar
idade ea minha interpretação dos
ensinamentos da humanidade a velha disse
mas sim o meu filho não deixou de
visitar o marido tem razão
não deixe de visitar sempre que via as
cavas encontrar aí o teu pirão a tua
cabeça dela com muito gosto a galinha de
cabidela gostas
nunca deixe de vir cá nós é que vamos
até o encontro na cidade e vamos levar a
galinha
vamos fazer lá e mais uma vez a minha
pequenez de intelectual não alcançou a
venda estava a dizer até que um dia nós
vivemos aqui próximo
víamos há dinheiro na cidade própria
casa
aí por volta das 18 30
e eu digo afrouxar o cara porque a
passar um grupo do capricho meu filho no
banco de trás
os clamores o papa aqueles cães são
diferentes
enquanto a minha esposa do lado seria
uma ferramenta foi a mensagem da mãe da
menina depois de um dia teve a
oportunidade de voltar a estar com ela e
na minha maior ironia ao dci o mais
velha a senhora não disse que ia mandar
também capricho
eu estava à espera apenas as galinhas e
disse mesmo assim disse ela sem o meu
filho não chove bem há dois anos o valor
que fica abaixo o passo pascar cabrito
não pode morrer
devemos que mandar os tablets
no mesmo ano foi convidado pelo
inabilitado por um amigo de jó alto
funcionário da oea no habitáculo quênia
convidou mesmo para a conferência sobre
a terra e desenvolvimento urbano
naturalmente que eu cheguei o quênia
sentei-me com john e coloquei nas minhas
preocupações e o destino paulo
o que vocês têm que fazer em angola eh
eh eh a forçar a vossa capacidade de
planificação está urbana para acolher os
milhares que ainda estava vivo e ainda
viram própria proximidade do campo para
a cidade
eu disse joe muito obrigado mas não esse
conselho que eu estou à procura
eu estou à procura de alguém que me diga
como é que eu vou transformar a minha
habitação rural
como é que eu vou melhorar o nível da
habitação no meio rural com recursos
locais que nós temos
sem ter que mandar vem da china e pagará
preço do petróleo
eu estou à procura de alguém jogo vai
conseguir dizer como é que eu vou
reabilitar dos sistemas de energia
locais para que tenhamos energia também
na zona euro vai para que também temos
de ver televisão
queremos transformar os nossos produtos
e conservar o saque localmente não vá
para a cidade vender a um preço
competitivo e assim permitir que vocês
na cidade tenham alimentação de
qualidade produtos de qualidade
eu ainda disse joel estou à procura de
alguém vai conseguir
fazer ajudar a reestruturar um sistema
de terras para que cada camponês consiga
ter no mínimo 85 6 hectares de terra
espaço contíguo e permitir fazer
economia de escala
quando nós multiplicar 156 hectares por
dois milhões quinhentos de 70 mil
famílias
claramente nós vamos perguntar mas
porque a gente tem fome é longo temos
potencial
eu disse o jogo estava à procura de
alguém que me desse um concelho como é
que eu poderia transformar o sistema de
educação rural no sentido permitir que
eu introduzi se na china nos no primeiro
ciclo escolar a disciplina da
agricultura para que as crianças no meio
rural consigam que cheira usar um
sentido científico das práticas que vêm
os pais fazerem anos
isso já estava procurando alguém que não
pudesse ensinar um pudesse ajudar a
estruturar uma disciplina de economia
rural para permitir que os jovens dos
ensinos menu meio rural sabendo do
potencial está à sua volta
sabendo como é que eles podem
transformar o seu potencial e que as
oportunidades não estão apenas no clã e
foi nessa perspectiva que eu abandonei a
conferência isso eu vou procurar outro
tipo de conselho e eu acho que é
possível sim nós transformamos o nosso
meio eu acho que é possível termos uma
escola rural feliz e para termos essa
angola do office não depende só das
pessoas estão no meio rural depende de
vocês
o mais velho maioridade à venda
miquelina passar uma bola pra esse lado
chutaram para vós a baliza a bola está
do vosso lado
e vossa responsabilidade agora chutarem
a bola de volta para empatar o jogo
neste momento 10 a responsabilidade de
equilibrar isso a vossa responsabilidade
criar um equilíbrio no meio toró é vossa
muito obrigado